[Music]
oh-oh-oh
fields the fields are coming Rose I
dream about you but every day and every
night dream about you but every day I
think about how it floats in the air it
makes me wanna say hey hey hey I wanna
look about you cuz but I know I can't
they are like sand papers from the wind
I don't know what to say that would
convince you the ditch that yeah it's
okay to like a bunch it's okay it's okay
it's I'm so sorry road redemption alpha
holy [ __ ] I am one single plain place so
this game I remember I played on this
Sega Genesis maybe when I was a little
boy and I remember i broke my cousin's
controller and I cried actually it's not
a good feeling I don't want to play with
him as a keyboard I want to play with my
[ __ ] controller that I don't tell me
what to play with all right [ __ ] all
right we're playing wedding quarterly so
your your remote it back
whoa and your jaw I don't tell me what
you do and your job is to kill other
people at least that's what I that's
what I remembered oh you can take
shortcut in [ __ ] holy [ __ ] this is
amazing oh god maybe this is not the
fastest way has it been proven by
science I don't think so so one is my
spiky claw hey what are you doing
[ __ ] off Oh God Oh God sorry oh right in
the titty Oh got you bit yesica tada
oh oh the caps what are you gonna do
kids
oh I'm retch
no [ __ ] what happened they're not number
one here we're catching up on him come
here come here you tosser haha [ __ ] one
more slap my [ __ ] up that's how we do
it in the port of my town it's the best
town in the world Oh God
sure we're almost there pass the per
vine and we're getting Josh [ __ ] yes
Oh something bad happened over there and
I don't even look at it because cool gas
don't look good explode
I have a katana now awesome
the GTI riders or cops no I am against
cops no I'm against killing cops all
right let's slice this guy what are you
doing oh god oh god what is it gonna
happen amazing uh-oh I tap that [ __ ] oh
hello I sliced him before he died died I
died I died
whoa whoa whoa hello don't hurt the
police unless the police is corrupt then
it's okay that's what movies taught me
there we go
you're welcome Jason Tate wasn't very
Tate if you know what I'm saying I am
trying to be a rapper here so don't
judge I really want to be a rapper one
day so please don't judge my rhymes
there you go he judged my rhymes one
thing see what happens when you judge my
rhymes all Frisch dies that's what
happens you are left unaffected so don't
worry about la freaking ninjas and motor
sick what happened Oh crash what it just
[ __ ] changed mission try not to blow
yourself up okay thanks game thanks for
just [ __ ] oh hello nitro double tap
oh damn Sam had a lamb in his watch oh
my god what is happening dances oh what
a sight I'm out of nitro alright that's
cool
wait up sir sir sir would you kindly
wait up oh god oh god yeah we're fine
Hey Oh God oh [ __ ]
Oh Jason's date said Jason oh my god I
got a samurai sword all right so you can
relieve pipe bombs on them that's
amazing take it here a present for you
it's Christmas don't worry about it
don't worry about you can pay me later
I'm a cc
Oh got it keep tapping out [ __ ] me this
is so exhilarating I can blow up cars
because of why not
here present free it's free free of
charge only Beth definitely only charge
okay oh my god oh god
nitro initiate nature I don't have a
helmet whoa I probably should have a
helmet Oh God
short cut this nuts work very well
ah oh I finished first let's blow up
that car for emergencies okay I kind of
like that was awesome level for how long
just keep going this is amazing level
four okay so now I have okay I have a
dynamite [ __ ] I have a rear mirror -
that's awesome that's awesome
amazing awesome awesome don't press in
it just go with it
how many do I have infinite okay well I
might as well have fun with it then Wow
I'm usually not a huge fan of remakes
but this is like [ __ ] worthless they
drive like mania Vanya I don't have my
same outfit how [ __ ] dare you have
the same outfit as me don't you know I
don't you dare slice to me there you go
christmas comes early this year but jess
oh god I got out now don't hit me
I have a sledgehammer sledgehammer Camp
sob sledge-hammering oh god I mom said
I'm almost dead I'm all said have a gift
Oh God who's smoking Nitra time
oh my god I'm all the said I got someone
every are my true
what was that car do it did you say that
freaking mountain goat car
alright level five it traffic flow crazy
mode oh [ __ ] yeah there is
Oh for [ __ ] sake oh god I'm alive I
don't know how nitro Oh for the love of
oh I'm so dead oh [ __ ] this is not a
good time tonight show Oh mamma mia
pizzeria oh [ __ ] how how am i okay well
I'm losing so I better catch up a little
bit
Oh God gotta love the rag doll
oh god I can't see anything oh that car
doing on top of that cottage I'm fourth
place oh never mind I made it I knew
that oh hello oh and that's how the
cookie crumbles how all that I have a
Swedish outfit by the way
so when I point that bog okay really
balancing oh come on give me a break
here
what is that guy doing in the rough Wow
not even second place try not to lose so
badly next time oh shut up that was
impossible
can we get like Dynamite's in this that
would be awesome now this is same mode
okay oh I can kick them too all right
that's cool I feel like the music in the
background should have a little bit more
oomph into it if you're not the same oh
my god oh my god
Jesus Oh oh my let's try a kick on this
guy if we can make it out alive that is
of course oh I doubt it
for [ __ ] sake oh [ __ ] the kick is
awesome and there we go Oh jump on the
car
if everyone in the entire goddamn world
on meth and it's that guy hitting with
my god damn shower shower what's up dog
come on I could win this I'm number one
no matter although be ChaCha's just
don't if no cars explode out oh no oh no
we're fine ah no cable plane huh oh no
don't hit me I don't have a lot of help
please please let the exit be near oh
come on
yes Josh [ __ ] Josh next round Oh
minecraft weird edit press have I boom
that's not easy
blow everything up alright let's do this
I have pipe bombs now again surprise I'm
from fortify your box yet that's love
right there
Oh see you later Dominic oh god where's
the bomb oh geez now a random car gets
to be blowed up cuz why not
nice job those writer learn their lesson
ow don't wear the same matching outfits
as more course tours
really just what I thought this game
couldn't get any more ridiculous and
over-the-top oh this is almost as
amazing as sharknado
oh my game of the year oh I have a pipe
what am I supposed to do Oh oh my god
what have we done to deserve this
please most this is what we do this is
our what we have to pay for Miley Cyrus
[ __ ] I think the exit is here what is
that oh god can we make it yeah [ __ ]
good job thanks thanks I appreciate it
old vehicles hate you I have a shovel
now though oh come on alright that's all
I had time for today breasts this is so
amazing you play it really felt like
going back you know so I'm a little
nostalgic to this I'm eight I mean I may
be a little biased but I thought this
was amazing I think you were sued for
[ __ ] sake I think you should should
definitely check this out I'll leave a
link in description thank you for liking
and commenting as always on this video
and thank you for hanging out with me
today that's all for me that's always
say awesome bros brophy
[Music]